Bonjour à tous.
Je suis très heureux de vous inviter
à l'Université de rentrée du MoDem
qui se déroulera
le 29, 30 septembre et 1ᵉʳ octobre.
Donc, dès aujourd'hui, inscrivez-vous,
mobilisez autour de vous.
Aussi bien nos adhérents,
nos militants que des amis,
des compagnons de route
qui ont envie de venir
débattre avec nous.
On ne vient jamais à Guidel par hasard
et cette année, c'est une année de congrès.
Au début de l'année prochaine,
il y aura notre congrès
du Mouvement Démocrate
et donc c'est le moment de commencer
à réfléchir ensemble.
Et puis, je crois qu'il y a une deuxième raison
qui est très importante,
c'est que les Français
ont besoin de ressentir,
qu'on est en phase avec eux,
qu'on entend leurs attentes
et que nous allons poser ensemble
des constats, des perspectives
et la vision dont le pays a besoin.
À très vite.